Salut, ici Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Salut tout le monde. Tout d'abord, je tiens à dire que je suis vraiment navré pour tout le retard que j'ai pris dans la publication de l'épisode.
Le mois de mars a été absolument ingérable pour moi. J'aurais quelques nouvelles importantes à partager en fin de cet épisode, notamment en ce qui concerne la fameuse formation que je vais donner en avril.
Donc écoutez bien jusqu'au bout. Aujourd'hui, un épisode très particulier, puisque c'est tout un témoignage, un partage d'expérience de la part d'un profil qu'on entend très rarement, à savoir un fou.
J'en avais parlé il y a quelques mois dans un édito, j'ai assez peu de patience pour les personnes qui emploient des mots comme schizophrène alors que très clairement, ils ne savent pas de quoi elles parlent.
Du coup, on prend le temps de parler avec mon invité de sa schizophrénie, de la psychophobie qui habite notre société, de l'institution qu'est la psychiatrie et du mouvement qui s'y oppose, à savoir l'antipsychiatrie.
C'est aussi la toute première fois que j'interviewe quelqu'un sous pseudonyme et on explique pourquoi dans l'interview. C'est parti.
Tu vois, ça, c'est quand t'entends des voix, c'est sympa parce qu'elles sont toutes en train de réfléchir à haute voix en même temps. Du coup-
Mais bien sûr
Un peu chiant.
Tu peux leur dire bonjour pour moi.
Ça marche.
J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Dandelion. Bonjour Dandelion.
Salut.
Est-ce que tu peux te présenter pour celles et ceux qui ne te connaissent pas encore ?
Ouais, bonjour tout le monde. Donc moi, c'est Dandelion, j'ai 32 ans. Je suis doctorant en études théâtrales.
Je suis auteur, puis j'ai eu plein de casquettes par le passé. J'ai plus de travail rémunéré actuellement, mais j'ai été prof à l'université et en cours particuliers.
Je suis traducteur et sinon, pour le sujet qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui, je suis, pour le dire avec les mots du médical, schizophrène paranoïaque.
Et pour le dire avec mes mots à moi, je suis fou et entendeur de voix.
Et dans ce cadre-là, je tiens un blog autour de la folie pour permettre aux gens dans la même situation que moi d'avoir des outils pour comprendre ce qui leur arrive et mieux le vivre au quotidien.
Voilà. Et donc on va parler ensemble de tes sujets, à savoir la folie, la schizophrénie, la psychophobie, la psychiatrie, tous ces sujets connexes.
Puisque voilà, j'ai cru comprendre que énormément de gens étaient familiers avec ces notions, mais en fait très ignorants et disaient beaucoup de bêtises à ce sujet.
On sait que le mot schizophrène, on va revenir là-dessus, est souvent employé par des personnes qui ne savent pas ce que ça veut dire.
Donc on va explorer tous ces sujets-là ensemble. Et donc on précise qu'on te présente uniquement par ton prénom parce que voilà, tu souhaites garder un anonymat relatif.
Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ? C'est assez simple, justement parce que la schizophrénie, c'est encore un mot qui fait énormément peur et du coup, les personnes schizophrènes subissent beaucoup de stigmatisation
et qu'effectivement, si je suis ouvertement décrit comme schizophrène, je m'expose à certaines violences.
Voilà, c'est pas rare de perdre son emploi quand on est connu comme schizophrène.
Moi, dans le cadre universitaire, j'ai dû faire face régulièrement à des profs qui passent 10 minutes à t'expliquer que les personnes folles ne sont pas capables de réfléchir.
Ce genre de choses. J'ai eu des profs aussi qui m'ont expliqué les yeux dans les yeux que parce qu'ils supposaient que telle personne était potentiellement psychotique, on ne pouvait pas croire un traître mot de ce qui était dit.
Donc effectivement, moi, je vis avec l'inquiétude que si ça se sait trop à l'université que je suis schizophrène, tout le travail de recherche que je fournis soit complètement dévalorisé,
et mis à la poubelle et que j'ai pas le droit de soutenir, par exemple.
Voilà, et c'est des choses qui potentiellement se sont vues, donc je suis un peu obligée d'être sous-marin.
Ouais, c'est très légitime et on comprend tout à fait. Et du coup, je disais il y a une seconde que les gens connaissaient le mot schizophrène, mais en fait ne savaient pas ce que ça voulait dire.
Est-ce que tu peux expliquer aux gens, pour commencer, pour introduire le sujet tout doucement, qu'est-ce que c'est en fait, la schizophrénie ?
Alors, c'est pas évident puisque c'est une maladie où effectivement, c'est très différent en fonction des personnes, mais dans ce qui va se retrouver en général, on a deux grandes catégories de symptômes.
On a ce qu'on appelle les symptômes positifs, donc qui ajoutent quelque chose. Donc dans cette catégorie-là, tu vas avoir tout ce qui est de l'ordre des hallucinations.
Tout le monde n'hallucine pas, mais tous les schizophrènes n'hallucinent pas, mais y en a. Tu vas avoir tout ce qui est de l'ordre du délire.
Et donc là, t'as des grandes familles de délires qui existent, tout ce qui va être des délires de persécution. Tu as les délires de,
de domination, tu vois, quand t'es le roi du monde ou quand tu es Dieu, les délires où tu es persuadé que telle personne est amoureuse de toi, etc.
Enfin, voilà, y a plusieurs grandes familles comme ça. Et plus généralement, ça va être une difficulté à distinguer ce qui est réel et ce qui ne l'est pas.
Et de l'autre côté, on va avoir tout ce qui est de l'ordre des symptômes négatifs. Donc là où on enlève quelque chose.
Donc ça va être des difficultés de concentration, des difficultés à reconnaître ses émotions ou à en avoir, des fois, carrément.
Ça va être des difficultés cognitives, donc quand il faut déclencher une action, quand il faut la faire, la perception du temps, en général, elle est abîmée, la mémoire peut être compliquée aussi.
Et donc en fonction des personnes, voilà, ça va aller piocher un petit peu dans ces différents éléments, à des degrés plus ou moins élevés.
OK. Est-ce que tu peux nous parler peut-être un peu de ton expérience à toi ? Est-ce que donc du coup, tu es diagnostiqué depuis combien de temps et quel rapport tu as avec ce diagnostic ?
Alors moi dans mon expérience à moi, la schizophrénie c'est énormément d'hallucinations. J'ai un cerveau qui est très productif là-dessus, là, il est très très doué là-dessus.
J'entends des voix avec lesquelles je vis plus ou moins en paix maintenant. Je suis paranoïaque et j'ai plusieurs délires en fonction des périodes.
Donc moi, je suis dans des délires notamment de corps qui pourrit beaucoup et autres délires où je n'existe pas, tout simplement.
Je suis diagnostiquée depuis mes 20 ans à peu près, donc ça fait une bonne douzaine d'années et mon rapport au diagnostic, il a évolué au fil du temps.
Ça a été un peu compliqué au début parce qu'on te balance un peu ce mot-là. En plus 'fin, c'est une histoire un peu chelou, mon moment de diagnostic, j'ai été diagnostiquée sans l'être.
Et le psy m'a à moitié engueulé au moment de-- c'était très bizarre. Mais c'est pas le sujet.
Ce sera le sujet après hein, le rapport du corps médical à la folie de manière générale. Mais on y arrivera dans un instant.
C'est ça. On va essayer de pas tout embrouiller dès le début.
Donc oui, donc j'ai été diagnostiquée sans que-- ça a été sous-entendu, mais on me l'a pas dit officiellement, mais très clairement, ça a été fait dans mon dos, comme souvent de toute façon.
Et donc au début, c'était plutôt le coup de massue et un peu de déni aussi. Et moi, je ne supportais pas le fait que tout le monde me considérait comme malade.
En fait dès le début, j'ai eu un problème avec le fait qu'on me dise que je sois malade, parce que je trouvais que ça ne correspondait pas à l'expérience que je vivais.
J'avais aucun mal à admettre que j'étais dysfonctionnelle, ça très clairement hein, j'avais aucun souci là-dessus, mais dire que j'étais malade, ça me convenait pas.
Et donc au fil du temps, donc au début, y a eu beaucoup de : je mets ça sous le tapis, j'en parle pas aux gens avec qui je vis parce que de toute façon,
quand j'annonce que je suis schizophrène, c'est tu joues à la roulette russe en fait, avec tes amis, avec tes relations amoureuses, etc.
Et ça finit très souvent pas super bien en plus. Donc beaucoup de honte, beaucoup de secret.
Ensuite, y a eu une période où c'était
un peu l'extrême inverse où : OK, quitte à me faire rejeter pour ça, beh je vais le porter comme un drapeau, comme ça au moins les gens se barreront vite et puis basta, je vais faire peur aux gens, ça sera plus simple.
Et après, j'ai retrouvé un équilibre où finalement, j'ai fait la paix un peu avec ce mot-là, où voilà, c'est OK, c'est ce que je suis, etc.
Et depuis quelques années, c'est plutôt j'en ai rien à foutre d'être décrite comme schizophrène parce que en fait, c'est les mots du médical et ça me convient pas.
Et de plus en plus, je me décris comme entendeur de voix et comme une personne folle finalement, et ça me paraît beaucoup plus convenir à l'expérience qui est la mienne.
Voilà, une espèce de rapport comme ça un peu en dents de scie sur comment est-ce qu'on s'approprie cette identité-là, qui, comme tu le disais, y a beaucoup de choses qui sont projetées dessus sans qu'on sache ce que c'est vraiment.
Ouais, ouais, oui. Donc c'est intéressant. Donc on peut explorer un peu les différents mots, les différents termes et pourquoi y en a certains que tu préfères à d'autres.
Tu disais que tu avais beaucoup de mal au début avec le qualificatif de malade. Donc ça, c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui ?
C'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui. Alors c'est pour le coup, c'est très personnel et c'est pas nécessairement une volonté politique ou quoi.
C'est vraiment juste personnellement, je me suis jamais vécue comme malade. Comme malade mentale, ça m'a jamais semblé pour moi personnellement.
Qu'est-ce que tu places dans ce mot-là ? Qu'est-ce que ce mot-là contient, signifie pour toi ?
C'est difficile à dire. Je pense, en fait, il faudrait sans doute que tu poses la question à des gens qui le vivent comme une maladie mentale.
Je pense qu'ils auraient une réponse bien plus pertinente que la mienne.
Mais donc c'est un mot que tu fuis. Donc c'est un mot avec lequel tu es mal à l'aise.
Pour moi, personnellement, oui. Après, quand je parle en général, je l'utilise aussi parce qu'il y a des gens qui se reconnaissent très bien dedans, donc ça me gêne pas de l'utiliser par rapport à d'autres.
Mais c'est pas ma réalité, en tout cas.
Comment est-ce que tu as le sentiment d'être perçue quand tu annonces autour de toi,
quand tu arrives à trouver le courage et que tu te présentes, voilà, tu dis : « Bah moi, je suis schizophrène » ou alors, ou tu ne le dis pas ou tu préfères dire que tu es entendeur de voix.
Comment ça se passe ?
Pfff... Aïe, ça dépend des fois, ça dépend beaucoup. Après, je choisis beaucoup mieux mon entourage et je le prépare beaucoup mieux cette annonce-là aussi qu'avant, donc ça aide.
Mais au niveau des réactions, on a beaucoup de choses. Je peux te parler de mon ancienne coloc à l'époque qui avait, après cette annonce, caché tous les couteaux de l'appartement.
Voilà, ce genre de réaction-là.
OK. Et ça, ça te semble légitime ?
Non, absolument pas. Ne faites pas ça. C'est extrêmement violent et malaisant et tout ce que vous voulez. Donc voilà, donc ça, c'est la réaction très caricaturale, mais je trouve qu'elle...
C'est intéressant d'en parler parce que
ça dit très clairement quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de la méfiance automatique, où c'est des fois des gens que tu connais depuis des années ou avec qui tu as travaillé pendant un moment, d'un seul coup, tout ça, ça disparaît.
Parce que tu as dit le mot schizophrène et d'un seul coup, ces personnes-là ne voient plus que tout ce que le monde remplit avec ce mot-là, donc toutes les fictions, les médias, tout le côté menace, danger, violence, etc.
D'un seul coup, y a plus que ça qui existe, même si ça fait super longtemps que voilà, tu les fréquentes et que t'as jamais montré le moindre signe de tout ça, d'un seul coup, ça n'existe plus.
Ça, c'est une réaction qui est malheureusement assez courante. Voilà, y a ça. Il y a les gens qui pensent te faire un compliment, mais en fait sont psychophobes.
Voilà, toutes les remarques du genre : « Ah, mais toi, t'as pas l'air d'être malade » ou « Mais non, toi, t'es pas vraiment fou » ou « T'es pas comme les autres », voilà, tous ces trucs-là.
Y a pas longtemps, on m'a dit que j'avais pas l'air d'être autiste ou t'sais, c'est toujours-
Voilà
...c'est toujours nul. C'est tellement nul.
C'est ça. Toi-même, tu sais, c'est exactement la même chose pour la schizophrénie. Et le pire, c'est que t'as envie de leur répondre : « Mais en fait, si, j'ai complètement l'air schizophrène.
C'est juste que tu ne sais pas regarder et tu ne sais pas associer ces signes-là à la schizophrénie parce que les gens s'attendent à ce qu'un schizophrène soit quelqu'un qui se tape la tête contre les murs en hurlant, H24.
C'est la même chose pour les autistes.
On a un problème avec les murs. Alors que ça n'arrive que quand-- 'fin moi ça m'arrive éventuellement quand j'suis en crise quoi, et j'suis pas en crise H24.
Oui, oui, j'ai eu des autistes dans ma vie qui effectivement se font violence et se tapent sur les murs, etc.
Ce ne sont pas moins des personnes absolument formidables et intelligentes et brillantes quoi. Donc faut pas décrédibiliser les gens pour ça, 'fin c'est-
C'est ça. Et puis ne pas confondre un état de crise avec un état de tout le temps en fait. C'est dans le nom.
C'est un état de crise. Donc ça peut pas-- sinon tu meurs en fait, au bout d'un moment. C'est comme ça que ça marche.
Donc y a ces réactions-là, voilà, qui se croient gentilles et qui en fait sont de l'ordre de la minimisation et de l'invisibilisation des difficultés de la personne.
Finalement, parce que c'est un peu ça aussi hein, quand on dit : « Bah t'as pas l'air schizo, t'as pas l'air autiste », c'est que ça permet de plus prendre en compte les difficultés qui vont être causées par l'un ou par l'autre.
Tu as les réactions d'incompréhension, je dirais, de gens qui, pour le coup, ne comprennent pas justement ce que ça amenait derrière finalement.
Parce que quand tu dis : « J'suis schizophrène », en fait t'as rien dit, en vrai. Tu ne dis pas tout ce qui est de l'ordre des difficultés cognitives.
Tu ne dis pas tout ce qui est de l'ordre des difficultés à comprendre tes propres émotions. Tu ne dis pas ce que ça fait concrètement d'halluciner tous les jours, ou d'être parano.
'fin tout ça, tu le dis pas finalement. Et du coup, tu vois bien que les personnes en face comprennent pas complètement ce que ça implique, tout en ayant conscience que ce qu'elles savent est sans doute pas très juste.
Y a des personnes qu'ont cette honnêteté intellectuelle de se dire : « C'est sans doute pas ce qu'on me dit à la télé et ce que j'ai vu dans les films, mais du coup, j'sais pas ce que c'est. »
Alors si on s'intéresse au rapport que les gens en général, les gens dans la vraie vie, ont avec cette idée de la folie,
généralement, y a l'idée que la folie c'est être irrationnel, c'est, ça s'oppose à la raison, c'est, voilà on est tous capables de réfléchir ensemble, de s'accorder sur ce qu'est la réalité.
Et les fous de leur côté, ben on peut même pas leur parler, on peut même pas faire société avec eux parce qu'ils sont pas dans le vrai, ils sont pas dans le rationnel.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de cette façon de présenter les choses ?
Bah que ça témoigne surtout d'une grande ignorance de ce qu'est la folie. Là encore, parce que comme tu dis, on oppose la folie à la raison, on oppose la folie au rationnel.
Et en fait, surtout quand on fait ça, c'est qu'on considère la folie comme étant complètement déconnectée du monde,
comme si c'était quelque chose qui arrivait comme ça, pff, hop, ex nihilo, sorti d'on sait où, voilà, pas de chance, tu es fou.
Voilà, ça, ça sont des choses qui arrivent. Et comme s'y avait pas de cause ou alors des causes qu'on-- biomédicales, ils aiment beaucoup ça, biochimiques, c'est la faute de nos cerveaux.
'fin bref, comme s'y avait pas de cause vraiment. Alors que la folie est un produit du monde,
finalement. Y a des études historiques, sociologiques, qui montrent bien que on ne délire pas de la même façon, selon les époques, selon les lieux. Ça montre-
Un truc que j'ai pu entendre, c'est que les personnes schizophrènes en Inde, en Europe, en Afrique,
pour celles et ceux qui entendent des voix, les voix ont tendance à dire des choses différentes selon la région du monde dans laquelle on est.
Est-ce que c'est vrai ?
Oui, complètement. T'as des choses là-dessus qui ont été montrées et surtout, c'est pas du tout vécu de la même façon.
J'avais vu des choses là-dessus aussi où qu'effectivement, dans des pays comme l'Inde, 'fin-- en tout cas, plus généralement, des pays moins individualistes que les nôtres,
le fait d'entendre des voix n'était pas vécu comme une agression de prime abord, parce que justement, on est moins centré sur le sujet unique, tout seul, etc., et bien délimité.
Et du coup, entendre des voix est finalement pas une violence. Et donc effectivement, elles vont pas produire les mêmes discours.
Déjà, on se rend bien compte que la folie, c'est un produit de la société, du monde dans lequel tu vis. Donc à partir de là, ça n'a aucun sens de considérer la folie comme quelque chose de déconnecté du monde en fait.
La folie dit quelque chose du monde, c'est juste qu'elle ne le dit pas dans la même langue que le reste en fait. J'aime bien penser la folie comme une langue.
Souvent, je trouve que ça montre bien ce que c'est vraiment.
Finalement, c'est comme si nous, on parlait pas tout à fait la même langue que les autres, mais ça reste une langue avec sa logique à elle, sa grammaire, sa structure, sa construction, ses références.
Et donc on peut en faire sens. C'est juste qu'il faut prendre le temps et ça prend énormément de temps de l'apprendre et de la comprendre.
Et ce temps, on le prend assez peu et du coup, fatalement, bah les personnes folles, elles sont vouées à être de plus en plus déconnectées puisque le reste du monde ne fait pas ce travail d'apprentissage.
C'est pas la personne qui est en souffrance, parce que la folie, surtout au moment où ça se déclenche, c'est beaucoup de souffrance.
Ça aussi, souvent, on le passe sous le tapis. La personne-- c'est pas la personne qui est en souffrance, qui est en détresse, qui va pouvoir faire ce travail et cet effort de se reconnecter au monde en fait.
C'est au monde de prendre le temps d'entourer cette personne-là, de lui donner une certaine sécurité et de tendre la main finalement et de faire l'effort
d'apprendre sa langue pour comprendre ce qui se passe pour elle et la ramener dans le monde et la réinclure.
On n'est pas à l'extérieur de la société juste parce que, voilà, on est à l'extérieur et c'est comme ça. On est à l'extérieur de la société parce que la société nous met à l'extérieur en fait.
Oui, oui, OK. Alors on va revenir sur le rapport de la société à la folie dans un instant, mais j'aimerais qu'on termine d'abord par définir quelques notions.
Le délire, qu'est-ce que c'est ? Ça se produit quand ? Ça se présente comment ? Comment est-ce que tu expliquerais ça aux gens ?
Alors là aussi, c'est pas évident de l'expliquer simplement. Si je fais des articles qui prennent 15 minutes à lire, c'est que justement c'est-
Oui, c'est très cruel de ma part, désolé
...ouais, mais je vais essayer de faire au mieux. Un délire, comment ça se produit ? En général, un délire, là encore, il arrive pas tout seul. C'est une réaction
à quelque chose qui, pour la personne, est soit ingérable, soit c'est impossible d'en faire sens.
Ça va peut-être être plus facile si je vous donne un exemple concret, et ça va être très facile que vous le compreniez puisque vous l'avez tous vécu, à savoir la pandémie de Covid.
Quand c'est arrivé, moi, j'en étais déjà à un burn-out qui traînait depuis un an et demi. Donc j'étais pas super bien déjà de base.
Et j'arrivais un peu au bout, au bout du bout du bout du bout du rouleau. Et je commençais à surtout ne plus comprendre ce qui se passait.
Donc comme tout le monde, ce moment-là où on a commencé à confiner, on a commencé à entendre parler du Covid partout sans trop comprendre ce qui se passait.
Je me rappelle plus comment c'était en Belgique, mais en France, y avait les pénuries de masques, de gel hydroalcoolique.
'Fin, c'était hyper chelou parce que d'un côté, on savait qu'il en fallait, mais on n'en avait plus. 'Fin, et beaucoup d'injonctions contradictoires de la part du gouvernement.
Et au bout d'un moment, c'était devenu tellement ingérable pour moi que quand Macron a annoncé : « On déploie l'armée pour aider à gérer sur le territoire, etc., le confinement.
» J'ai-- je suis devenue complètement délirante, j'ai décompensé. Où dans ma tête, c'était Macron envoie l'armée pour tous nous tuer parce que, comme ça, les morts, ça transmet pas le Covid.
Mmm-hmm.
Et donc voilà, je mangeais plus, je dormais plus. 'Fin, c'était très compliqué. Et en fait, ce délire-là, il s'est mis en place parce que j'étais trop épuisée pour faire face et que comme tout le monde, j'avais du mal à comprendre ce qui se passait
et que de partir dans un truc comme ça, complètement délirant.
Alors, c'est pas un choix conscient que tu fais hein, c'est ton...
Ouais.
...ton cerveau qui à un moment : « OK, là, ça saute, y a des trous, le cerveau n'aime pas ça, n'aime pas le cerveau...
...l'humain n'aime pas qu'y ait des trous, donc je vais les boucher. »
Le délire a une fonction, ouais, boucher les trous pour retrouver une forme de contrôle sur...
C'est ça, une forme de contrôle.
...l'explication de ce qui se passe quoi. Ouais.
Une forme de contrôle, que ça ait du sens et que du coup, tu puisses savoir comment agir. C'est-à-dire je peux pas agir face à un virus.
Par contre, face à un militaire, ça, d'un seul coup, c'est vachement plus gérable, tu vois, entre guillemets.
Ouais.
Du point de vue de la folie, c'est plus facile. Mais voilà, c'est pas tout, c'est des...
C'est plus concret, disons, ouais.
...voilà, c'est vraiment ça le truc. C'est, ça veut pas dire que empiriquement, en vrai, c'est plus facile, mais c'est plus saisissable, on va dire.
Tu vois, savoir comment réagir face à un être humain qui a une arme, etc., c'est quelque chose sur lequel tu peux avoir prise.
Savoir comment réagir face à un truc qui est invisible, qui est hors de ton champ de compétence, parce que ben moi, j'suis pas biologiste, j'suis pas épidémiologiste, ni virologue, ni rien de tout ça.
Et en plus, on me donne plein d'injonctions contradictoires dans tous les sens. Ça, c'est compliqué et c'est insupportable et c'est douloureux.
Et donc tu parlais donc de cette idée que Emmanuel Macron allait envoyer l'armée pour exterminer les gens.
Ouais.
Là, 'fin présenté comme ça, ça évoque plutôt ce qu'on appelle la paranoïa.
Mmh.
Est-ce que tu fais des ponts ? Est-ce que tu fais des liens entre...
La paranoïa, si tu veux, c'est aussi une forme de délire, finalement hein. C'est des mots différents, mais en fait, c'est très poreux, tout ça.
Mmh, d'accord.
Et donc effectivement, comme moi, je suis paranoïaque, les délires que je développe sont pour beaucoup avec ce fonctionnement-là en sous-texte.
Effectivement hein, y a souvent une menace, y a souvent un danger ou un complot ou une persécution. Ça revient très souvent chez moi.
Donc c'est ce que je disais, c'est y a plein de familles de délires. Donc ça, c'en est une. Mais y en a d'autres.
Mais la mécanique de base, c'est un peu ça quoi, c'est...
J'aurais envie de présenter les choses comme ça. J'ai le sentiment que vivre en société ensemble, c'est... oh, je vais enfoncer des portes ouvertes, désolé.
C'est, voilà, c'est un peu partager une certaine culture, une certaine réalité commune.
Jamais entièrement, évidemment, mais voilà, on vit ensemble et on a des références communes au réel et au fonctionnement de la société.
Dès le moment où on considère que le fait de délirer, c'est finalement relativement banal, c'est quelque chose qui fait partie de la vie...
Mmh.
...est-ce que ça, par définition, ne casse pas ce ciment, ce liant entre nous ?
Puisque, bah peut-être que mon voisin, il a pas du tout, du tout, du tout le même rapport à la réalité que moi, puisque il est peut-être concerné, comme toi, par, voilà, il entend des voix ou il a le sentiment que,
la gravité ne fonctionne pas de la même manière que moi ou tu vois ?
Est-ce que ça n'est pas vraiment un obstacle important au fait de faire société ?
Ça dépend ce que t'appelles faire société. C'est-à-dire que ça...
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
...y a plusieurs niveaux dans ce que tu dis. Donc oui, y a la porte ouverte que on fait société quand on partage une histoire commune ou que
une culture commune, bla bla bla, où on vit ensemble par la force des choses parce qu'on est sur le même territoire et qu'on obéit aux mêmes lois.
Donc ça, c'est une chose. Et finalement, c'est une chose sur lequel on n'a pas tellement de prise, je dirais.
Par défaut, je fais société avec tous les gens de mon immeuble, mais en fait, à part leur dire bonjour dans le hall, j'leur dis pas grand-chose.
Et donc faire société avec eux, finalement, ça revient à pas sacrifier de chèvres sur mon balcon et ne pas écouter du black metal à fond à 3 h du matin.
Ça se limite à ça finalement, à un espèce de respect commun. Alors qu'effectivement, partir du principe que,
faire société avec les gens que je côtoie vraiment, ma famille, mes proches, mes collègues, ces personnes-là, c'est différent finalement, parce que on doit activement trouver une base commune selon laquelle fonctionner,
qui dépasse un petit peu juste le simple vivre ensemble.
Et donc ça, que la personne face à toi, elle soit folle ou pas,
bah ça change rien finalement. Dans tous les cas, il faut faire ce travail de comment je peux fonctionner avec l'autre personne, soit parce que j'y suis obligée, soit parce que j'ai envie.
Et dans tous les cas, c'est un vrai travail à faire en fait. 'Fin...
Mmh.
C'est une illusion de se dire qu'on fait société facilement.
Non, jamais facilement.
Jamais facilement.
J'vais peut-être prendre un autre exemple parce que bon, moi comme toi, je parle extrêmement peu aux autres gens dans ce building d'appartement.
Mais voilà, si je reprends par exemple la situation de la pandémie où là, faire société, ça voulait dire : bon, y a un virus.
Au tout début, c'était le confinement. Bon, il faut pas que le virus circule, on reste tous bien chez nous dans le but de...
Mmh.
On s'accorde sur le fait que y a cette règle, y a cet intérêt commun et on reste tous enfermés chez nous, dans la mesure du possible.
Si maintenant, on ajoute à l'équation des personnes pour qui cette réalité-là n'existe pas du tout et ce virus est,
bah n'est pas considéré comme tel ou c'est considéré comme étant, voilà, pour une raison, un délire, un fantasme ou quoi, mais en fait non, il faut surtout pas rester enfermé chez nous.
Bah là, ça pose un... de nouveau, ça semble être un obstacle, non ? Qu'est-ce que t'en penses ?
En fait, c'est ça que j'essaie de t'expliquer, c'est que on est déjà de toute façon pas dans les mêmes réalités, en fait.
De toute façon, c'est une illusion de croire qu'on partage tous une réalité. C'est une illusion à laquelle on s'accroche parce qu'effectivement, j'pense que c'est trop compliqué.
On vit dans un monde qui est devenu trop grand pour pouvoir accepter que c'est qu'une illusion, mais c'est qu'une illusion.
C'est pour ça que, est-ce qu'on peut faire société avec des personnes qui sont folles, qui sont délirantes ?
La réponse, elle est oui, puisque de toute façon, pour faire société, il faut pouvoir s'adapter à tous. Le principe d'une société, le principe d'un collectif, c'est d'inclure les gens.
C'est censé protéger tout le monde. Et donc oui, on peut faire société avec des personnes qui vivent dans une réalité différente puisque de toute façon, qu'on le veuille ou non, c'est déjà le cas.
C'est juste que par contre, pour les personnes comme moi, pour les personnes folles, pour les personnes délirantes, c'est plus flagrant, on va dire.
C'est sûr que quand j'explique que Macron envoie l'armée pour tuer tout le monde, bon, c'est peut-être un peu too much.
Tu dis : « C'est plus flagrant. » Et en même temps, on a commencé l'interview et tu m'expliquais que tu étais un schizophrène sous-marin, et que les gens,
les gens ne savaient pas que tu entendais des voix ou que tu avais occasionnellement des délires.
Donc finalement, ça, c'est passé sans que les gens le sachent.
Parce que effectivement, dans mon cas, je fais partie des schizophrènes qui passent bien. Parce que j'arrive quand même à savoir à qui je peux dire quoi.
Donc effectivement, à mes collègues, parce qu'à l'époque, je travaillais encore,
j'ai juste dit que j'étais en dépression suite, 'fin voilà, suite à un burn-out et que je prenais un peu du recul, que le Covid, la crise Covid m'avait achevée.
J'ai juste dit ça, par exemple. Et effectivement, j'ai la chance que quand je me mette à délirer, ça soit rarement à un point où je peux pas m'empêcher de dire les choses.
J'arrive toujours, j'ai peut-être l'avantage d'être paranoïaque, justement. J'ai un système de défense là-dessus qui est assez solide où effectivement, j'arrive toujours à cacher ça.
Je pense que c'est ce qui m'a sauvée à l'époque face aux psys et qui a fait que j'ai pas fini en hôpital psy. Qu'effectivement, j'arrive à repérer ce qui est pas dans la bonne langue, si tu veux.
J'arrive à savoir que ça, c'est la langue de la folie.
Et du coup, on ne parle pas la langue de la folie avec ses collègues, on ne parle pas la langue de la folie devant un psy, on ne parle pas la langue de la folie avec qui que ce soit qui peut avoir du pouvoir sur moi, finalement.
Et donc j'arrive à le cacher.
Est-ce que y a une forme de communauté des personnes folles, des personnes schizophrènes où voilà, vous partagez un, oui, un sentiment d'appartenance ?
Est-ce que ça existe ou bien est-ce que vous êtes tous dans votre coin ?
Alors, ça existe. Internet a beaucoup aidé à ça.
Ouais, ouais, ouais, j'imagine.
Ça permet de trouver des gens comme nous entre guillemets, qui parlent la même langue et à qui je peux dire ces choses-là et, même si elles sont pas dans le même délire,
elles peuvent comprendre quand même d'une certaine façon ce que je vis.
C'est pour ça que ta question sur est-ce qu'on peut faire société avec des personnes délirantes, peut-être j'arrive pas à y répondre correctement ou à expliquer.
Mais quand je vois qu'on arrive à faire communauté entre personnes folles qui sont dans des délires qui peuvent être très très différents, qu'ont rien à voir les uns avec les autres et qu'on arrive quand même
à faire communauté, à trouver un socle commun,
j'ai du mal à comprendre que ce soit pas possible pour les plus larges.
Mais donc oui, y a des choses qui peuvent se dire entre personnes folles qui ne peuvent pas se dire, je pense, avec des personnes non folles.
Pas parce que, 'fin voilà, j'ai des proches qui sont pas fous, et qui sont très capables de m'entendre, mais y a toujours quelque chose qui échappe, je pense.
Et c'est pas le cas avec d'autres personnes folles. On arrive quand même plus facilement à retrouver comment se parler et la logique de ça.
Parce que je pense, c'est sans doute lié aussi, je pense, tant qu'on l'a pas vécu.
Ce que les gens comprennent pas face à un délire, c'est que c'est pas quelque chose sur lequel on a prise, au sens où il suffit pas de se dire : « Ceci est délirant » pour que ça s'arrête, en fait.
C'est-à-dire que même moi, au stade où j'en suis, où je parais être stable et où, très en maîtrise, je suis capable de voir : « Tiens, là, je suis en train de devenir complètement délirante », mais en fait, c'est pas ça qui fait que ça s'arrête.
Et des fois, tu te vois délirer complètement et tu peux pas arrêter et tu peux juste subir.
Et ça, je pense que c'est compliqué pour les personnes non délirantes à comprendre que, bah justement, ce qu'on se disait au début sur l'opposition folie-raison et qu'en fait, tu peux faire les deux en même temps.
Et ça, les personnes folles le comprennent.
Alors du coup,
t'auras peut-être pas forcément envie de répondre, mais,
est-ce que du coup, là maintenant, y a des choses que tu n'oserais pas, que tu n'aurais pas spontanément envie de me dire parce que je suis pas catalogué comme fou ?
Sans doute moins parce que t'es pas catalogué comme fou que parce que t'es en train d'enregistrer ça et que tu vas le diffuser en public.
OK. Tu n'es pas tombé dans mon piège.
Voilà, exactement. Je suis trop malin.
OK, bah une autre question alors. C'est un exemple de délire que tu donnais dans un de tes articles et qui me semble vraiment bien illustrer ce que peut être un délire.
Mais alors, 'fin c'est seulement si tu es d'accord pour en parler, mais c'était la situation où tu avais le sentiment, t'avais l'impression d'avoir des pierres dans ton corps.
C'est un truc, c'est une sensation qui revient plus ou moins régulièrement. En fait,
c'est pour ça que c'est compliqué de te répondre sans question précise, parce que c'est une sensation que j'ai régulièrement et qui peut avoir différentes causes.
L'une des fois où je m'en souviens le plus vivement, y a quelques années, j'ai fait un kyste ovarien.
Et sauf que, comme souvent, j'ai traîné à me faire soigner pour diverses raisons. Et en fait, la douleur, au bout d'un moment, c'était vraiment ça.
C'était, j'étais persuadée d'avoir des cailloux dans mon corps, etc. Au point que j'ai fait des crises psychotiques à devoir me retenir d'aller chercher un couteau de cuisine pour les en sortir, histoire de régler le problème.
Et c'est assez rigolo parce que du coup, quand j'ai finalement fini par aller me faire soigner et qu'on a fait les échographies, on s'est rendu compte que y avait effectivement un caillou dans mon corps.
Donc c'était assez étrange. Et des fois, la folie, elle fait ça, c'est-à-dire qu'elle te donne la réponse de façon extrêmement littérale.
J'étais persuadée d'avoir des cailloux dans mon corps, je pouvais les sentir, etc. Et c'était effectivement ce qui se passait.
C'est-à-dire que cette douleur-là qui empirait de mois en mois et que j'ai traîné à faire soigner,
comme je traînais à la faire soigner et que je n'avais pas de réponse, la folie, elle a donné celle-là : on a des cailloux dans le corps.
Après, c'est une sensation que j'ai régulièrement, qui peut être moins localisée. Plus généralement, c'est moins des cailloux dans le corps que des lames de rasoir dans les veines.
J'ai des espèces de douleurs hallucinées comme ça et qui viennent souvent traduire soit des moments où je me sens lourde et où j'ai du mal à fonctionner.
Et je pense que c'est une matérialisation
très, très viscérale, pour le coup, d'un épuisement ou d'une difficulté que j'arrive plus à surmonter, mais comme je n'arrive pas à la nommer ou que je ne prends pas le temps de m'occuper de moi, ce qui est aussi un de mes problèmes,
effectivement, ça finit par se traduire comme ça.
Ou parce que j'ai subi une violence, 'fin quelque chose que j'estime violent, que j'arrive pas à... C'est-à-dire que c'est une violence qui est des fois tellement improbable
que je n'arrive pas à intégrer qu'elle puisse être réelle, en fait.
Ça me dépasse. Et du coup, quand je suis dans cet état-là, c'est une sensation que je peux avoir. Parce que comme ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure, bah avoir des cailloux dans le corps, avoir des lames de rasoir dans les veines, ça existe.
C'est quelque chose qui d'un seul coup prend une forme, et c'est compréhensible. Ça a pas de raison d'être là, chimiquement parlant, biologiquement parlant, mais ça, c'est saisissable, en fait.
Je peux dire : « J'ai mal ». Ça y est, je peux décrire cette émotion-là. L'émotion et ce que je ressens, c'est : j'ai mal.
Je souffre, j'ai mal, voilà. Et le délire permet d'avoir quelque chose, en tout cas, que je puisse saisir et autour duquel se rassembler, le temps qu'après,
je puisse être dans un état d'esprit où j'ai le temps de m'arrêter pour me dire : « OK, en fait, il s'est passé ça, ça, ça et c'est pour ça que je ressens ça, etc.
» Voilà, ça prend le relais, si tu veux.
Tu reçois un signal de ton esprit, ton cerveau, t'as vraiment l'impression de percevoir quelque chose.
Mmh.
Et puis tu dois vraiment avoir des réflexes, prendre une initiative pour remettre ça en question, ce qui doit être super dur puisque,
moi par exemple, là je sais que y a un micro devant moi, je sais que je suis en train de te parler.
Si je dois arriver à remettre ça en question et me dire : « Mais en fait peut-être que c'est le fruit de mon imagination, que Dandelion n'existe pas. »
Ouais.
C'est assez violent.
Et puis je te le confirme en plus, je n'existe pas, je ne suis qu'une histoire que tu...
Ah oui, c'est vrai que, c'est vrai que
...racontes aux uns et aux autres. Donc c'est pas de chance pour toi, là.
Oui, c'est vrai que tu as cette, voilà, cette impression-là aussi. Quelque chose que j'ai pu lire encore une fois dans tes articles, c'est, je cite : « Les fous, les folles sont un symptôme, une conséquence.
Nous sommes ce que le monde produit à force de violence, de dysfonctionnement, de rejet, de violence. » T'as écrit deux fois « violence ».
Bah je devais trouver que c'est vachement violent le monde.
De violence...
Je m'y trompe pas forcément toujours, donc des fois oui.
...d'injonctions contradictoires et d'incohérences. Donc oui, on parlait tout à l'heure du fait que c'était largement un produit sociétal.
Est-ce que toi, tu peux nous parler dans ton cas personnel ? Est-ce que tu as le sentiment que ta nature, le fait d'entendre des voix, c'est le produit d'un monde violent ?
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler de ça ?
Oui, moi j'ai clairement cette sensation-là. C'est aussi quelque chose que je vois avec toutes les personnes folles que j'ai pu croiser, soit ponctuellement, soit sur le long terme.
Et en fait quand t'en prends conscience, tu le vois d'autant mieux, que les moments où tu redeviens extrêmement délirant ou la folie elle reprend le pas, c'est là aussi souvent pas des moments sortis de nulle part.
C'est-à-dire que je vois bien dans mon évolution les moments où je me suis stabilisée, c'est des moments où effectivement dans ma vie, ça allait mieux.
Et puis y a eu des traumas qui se sont ajoutés, d'un seul coup ça s'est redégringolé. Puis ça s'est restabilisé et puis la précarité et des grosses galères et re d'autres claques dans la gueule.
Et tu vois bien, tu vois bien ce mouvement-là en fait se faire. Quand tu commences à y réfléchir, tu vois bien que c'est pas juste ton cerveau qui, au pif, envoie des neurotransmetteurs n'importe comment.
Tu vois bien quand même que c'est une réaction à des choses qui se passent autour de toi.
Un exemple qui est intéressant, c'est le fait qu'aux États-Unis, les personnes afro-américaines ont deux fois, trois fois, quatre fois plus de chances d'être diagnostiquées psychotiques que les Blancs.
Mmh.
Donc est-ce que y a une notion d'intersectionnalité ? Parce qu'on parlait, voilà, de violence.
Ouais.
Est-ce qu'il y a une notion d'intersectionnalité qui fait que les personnes racisées vont être davantage concernées par la folie ?
Y a complètement une notion d'intersectionnalité puisque déjà, les personnes non blanches sont effectivement plus exposées à la violence puisque là on est dans un monde qui est systémiquement raciste.
Donc plus exposées à la violence, plus exposées à la pauvreté, plus exposées à la précarité et donc à ce genre de situations qui produisent des maladies mentales, qui produisent de la folie.
Donc déjà y a ça effectivement, ce fait-là, que ce sont des populations qui sont bien plus fragiles, plus fragilisées plutôt, je devrais dire, face à tout ça.
Et tu as aussi, si y a ce surdiagnostic, c'est parce que dans l'imaginaire, la schizophrénie est associée à la violence, y compris chez nos amis les psychiatres, même s'ils se défendront du contraire,
et que les personnes non blanches et notamment les personnes noires sont elles aussi présumées violentes, quoi qu'elles fassent, en fait.
Donc y a ces choses comme ça qui se
mêlent et qui produisent ce surdiagnostic. Et je crois que j'avais vu par contre, à l'inverse,
j'ai pas les chiffres en tête, mais à l'inverse, les populations noires sont sous-diagnostiquées au niveau de la dépression et l'autisme, par exemple.
Parce qu'on considère que, voilà, c'est un truc de Blanc, elles peuvent pas ressentir ça, etc.
Mmh, mmh. Ouais, ça me semble très crédible en effet. Un truc dont moi je me souviens, puisqu'on parlait des États-Unis,
c'est que quand je suis passé... C'était en 2017, je passais pendant quelques jours à San Francisco.
Et donc c'est une ville assez particulière puisque la Californie est considérée comme étant relativement à gauche aux États-Unis, tout est relatif.
Et donc ils ont des programmes importants en termes de... 'fin, importants, relativement importants pour des Américains, vis-à-vis des personnes sans domicile fixe.
Et donc y a beaucoup de villes américaines qui ont chargé des bus entiers pour envoyer tous leurs SDF en Californie et à San Francisco en particulier.
Et donc quand je suis arrivé là, en fait, oui, y a vraiment des quartiers qui sont remplis, remplis, remplis. Quand tu marches dans le Tenderloin la nuit, les rues sont remplies de SDF.
Beaucoup de consommation d'héroïne en pleine journée comme ça dans la rue.
Et un autre truc qu'on voit et qui, je dois confesser,
m'avait mis assez mal à l'aise, c'est voilà des gens qui se parlent tout seuls, qui ont clairement, bah qui semblent en tout cas avoir une conversation avec une autre personne dans leur tête.
C'est quelque chose qui est assez inquiétant. Est-ce que pour toi, y a une assistance à leur donner ?
Ou au contraire, faut les laisser tranquilles ?
Tu parles en tant que pouvoir public ou en tant qu'individu ?
Plutôt en tant que pouvoir public, en tant que système, en tant que société.
Bah déjà loger les gens, pour commencer.
Je comprendrai jamais quand on a autant de logements vides et que quand on prétend vouloir s'occuper des problèmes des SDF, la première logique soit pas loger les gens, en fait.
Tu as d'ailleurs des pays qui le font et, magique, ça résout le problème.
Est-ce que... Alors, je ne sais pas si c'est vrai, mais ce que disent les Américains quand on leur en parle, c'est souvent des : « They wanna be in the street.
» C'est l'idée que si on leur propose... Oui, non, c'est nul. Mais si on leur propose, ils vont refuser en gros, parce que y a cette méfiance des autorités quoi.
Alors, c'est encore une fois deux choses différentes. Déjà, on a des pays qui le font, donc on a les chiffres et on sait qu'effectivement quand tu loges les gens, oui, tu résous quand même une bonne partie du problème.
Ensuite, « They wanna be in the street. » Oui, bon, ça, je suis pas sûre.
Je, j'étais pas en train de défendre cette-
Non, non, je me doute, je me doute, t'inquiète. Bah tu parlais de la méfiance des institutions et oui, ça peut être un frein très sérieux, puisque ça va dépendre beaucoup de comment tu mets en place ton programme.
C'est-à-dire que si effectivement tu loges les gens, mais que ça se fait sous couvert d'un flicage assez sérieux, effectivement, y a des gens qui vont se dire que ben non, en fait, y a pas d'intérêt à y aller.
On voit ça déjà hein, dans certains programmes, même en France, où, OK, on te file un logement, mais on passe tous les deux jours voir que t'as fait le ménage ou 'fin voilà.
Où on exige finalement de ces populations-là beaucoup plus que ce qu'on exigerait de personnes valides, pas droguées, pas malades mentales, etc., finalement.
Donc effectivement, si ton programme d'assistance au logement se fait en échange d'un flicage assez extrême,
bah oui, potentiellement, les gens vont choisir la rue, mais c'est pas tellement la rue qu'ils choisissent, c'est juste de pouvoir vivre leur vie, en fait.
Donc c'est compliqué dans ce sens-là. Et quand on le pense comme ça, on n'est pas en train de réfléchir au prix qu'on fait payer à ces personnes-là.
C'est-à-dire que quand tu fliques les gens pour les loger, en fait ce que t'es en train de dire, c'est : certaines personnes méritent d'être logées correctement, méritent d'avoir accès à une vie décente.
Et quand on aura bien vérifié que oui, tu mérites tout ça, OK, on te donnera des droits. Finalement, des droits, ça se mérite.
Ça me paraît être un énorme problème que juste on est une société et du coup, on fait en sorte que tous les éléments de la société aient accès à une vie décente puisque, bah juste c'est comme ça en fait.
Les gens ont le droit d'avoir une vie décente et on n'a pas à gagner ce droit-là en fait. 'fin voilà, c'est un peu ces problèmes-là qui sont pas dits quand on dit que les gens choisissent la rue en fait.
C'est quand même un petit peu plus compliqué que ça.
On pourrait parler, l'espace d'un instant, de ce que c'est d'être dans l'entourage d'une personne concernée donc par, voilà, la folie de manière générale, ça peut être schizophrène ou autre.
Est-ce que c'est difficile ? Est-ce que c'est quelque chose dont... Tu as eu l'occasion d'écouter les témoignages de ces personnes-là et qu'est-ce que c'est de vivre dans l'entourage de, ben de toi, par exemple ?
Alors, je risque d'être assez acide dans ma réponse, je préviens d'avance. Justement parce que c'est pas difficile d'avoir accès à ces témoignages-là, puisque c'est ceux qu'on entend en priorité, les témoignages des proches.
C'est le cas aussi pour les personnes autistes où souvent, on va interviewer les parents d'enfants autistes qui vont en parler comme étant des gros poids avec lesquels il faut vivre, etc.
Je comprends tout à fait ce que tu dis, mais je voulais pas t'interrompre.
Voilà, donc toi-même, tu sais. Donc non, je n'écoute plus ces témoignages-là parce que en plus, 'fin voilà, ils sont douloureux, effectivement.
Déjà politiquement, parce que c'est à eux qu'on donne la parole en premier lieu avant de nous la donner à nous. Donc dans l'espace public de la prise de parole, ça mange de l'espace qui devrait nous revenir et que du coup,
on ne peut plus parler de nous-mêmes.
Et qu'en plus, souvent, comme tu le disais très bien, c'est quand même souvent des témoignages qu'on axe sur comment c'est pas facile.
Ce qui vient renforcer d'autant plus le fait que nous sommes des personnes pas faciles. Et du coup, c'est compliqué parce que je veux bien croire que oui, c'est pas toujours facile de me fréquenter.
Quand je suis en période de paranoïa, tu vois, j'ai pas pu... Là y a une dizaine de jours, pendant une semaine, j'avais pas le droit d'interagir avec les gens.
Donc j'ai systématiquement collé des gens à mon amoureuse, à des potes, etc.
Donc je pense que c'est pas facile à vivre, tu vois, quand tu es rejeté comme ça sans raison et sans prévenir par quelqu'un que tu aimes, je l'entends tout à fait.
Je pense que c'est pas facile à vivre quand je fais une crise, et qu'effectivement, je peux me mettre en danger ou que voilà.
Ou que dans d'autres cas, je perds l'accès à la langue, donc je peux plus parler, je peux plus m'exprimer et je comprends pas quand on me parle.
Objectivement, oui, c'est vrai que c'est pas facile, mais finalement, qui peut se targuer d'être facile à vivre ?
Je ne sais pas. J'ai plein d'amis qui sont pas fous, pas malades mentaux, et que pourtant, des fois, j'ai envie de dire : « Ils sont bien chiants aussi hein, à leur façon.
» Donc je pense que c'est des difficultés particulières quand tu fréquentes une personne folle.
Mais je trouve que la façon qu'on a de toujours centrer dans les discours : « Est-ce que c'est difficile d'être avec une personne schizophrène ?
Est-ce que blablabla ? » Finalement, ça vient recentrer systématiquement le fait que c'est difficile. Et ça entretient une image qui est déjà capable de pas besoin d'être entretenue, tout en effaçant les difficultés réelles.
C'est-à-dire que pendant que tu demandes à nos proches si c'est difficile d'être proche avec nous, t'es pas en train de leur demander ce qui se passe bien ou ce qui a pu être mis en place pour que justement ça se passe bien.
Ouais, et donc les personnes concernées sont effacées, par exemple des médias ou de, voilà, de la place publique.
De manière générale, on vous demande pas votre avis. C'est ça que tu dis ?
C'est ça, voilà. Et c'est compliqué de le dire parce que en même temps-
Mais attends, mais c'est ça que tu considères être acide ?
Mais parce que quand j'ai parlé publiquement de ça dernièrement, je te jure que j'ai eu des retombées, ça a pas été apprécié.
Parce que d'un côté, j'entends tout à fait qu'effectivement ça puisse être compliqué et que les proches puissent avoir besoin elles aussi d'espace pour parler de ces difficultés-là.
Hein, moi aussi hein, je fréquente... Moi aussi, je suis proche de personnes folles, accessoirement. Et donc oui, je sais que c'est pas toujours facile.
Je le sais aussi, mais
c'est comment à un moment, il faut aussi que nous, en tant que personnes proches,
en tant que proches de personnes folles, on comprenne que notre souffrance, c'est peut-être un trop grand mot, mais par rapport à tout ça, elle se place pas au même niveau que la personne qui est folle en fait.
Ça, c'est deux choses qui sont complètement différentes. Et on n'a pas à tirer la couverture à nous, en tant que proches, pour parler des difficultés des personnes autour de nous en fait.
C'est pas... Non, ça ne se fait pas.
Oui, oui. Alors on va aborder donc la question qu'on a toujours pas vraiment-
on a évoqué par détour, mais qu'on n'a toujours pas vraiment exploré, c'est-à-dire la notion, la question de la psychiatrie et des, voilà, des médecins et tout ça, dans un instant.
Mais juste avant ça, j'aimerais revenir sur l'exemple que tu as donné en tout début d'interview. Tu expliquais qu'il fallait surtout pas retirer tous les couteaux des tiroirs.
C'était ignorant et insultant quelque part.
Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer en quoi une personne qui est paranoïaque, qui a très peur, qui peut développer des peurs, des pensées complotistes vis-à-vis de son ou sa colocataire,
t'as expliqué que tu as pu occasionnellement être un danger pour toi-même.
En quoi est-ce que l'idée qu'une personne avec un profil comme celui-là soit un danger pour autrui ? En quoi est-ce que c'est une notion problématique ?
Elle est problématique parce qu'en général, c'est la pensée par défaut. C'est-à-dire que pour en revenir à cette histoire de ma coloc, je n'avais
aucune pensée comme quoi elle allait m'agresser, etc., que donc fallait que je me défende.
C'est elle qui a présumé, à partir du moment où j'ai dit que j'étais schizophrène, que j'étais dangereux. Et qui du coup, en conséquence, a fait en sorte que je n'aie pas, entre guillemets, d'armes.
Parce que c'est vrai que les couteaux des étudiants, c'est connu en général pour être super, super couteau, voilà.
Couteau à beurre.
Voilà, exactement. Que j'aie pas d'arme. Elle a vraiment présumé ça en fait, si tu veux. Alors qu'encore une fois, y avait aucun indice.
Et qu'éventuellement, dans mon cas, je vais généralement plutôt me faire du mal à moi qu'au reste du monde.
Et ça a été décidé avec les voix y a très longtemps, j'aurais le droit de faire du mal au reste du monde quand j'aurais fini de me massacrer moi.
Donc normalement, le reste, vous êtes tranquilles.
Il existe des personnes avec des, voilà... C'est un exemple un peu extrême hein, mais les gens qui font des massacres de masse dans les écoles aux États-Unis, par exemple, sont souvent concernés par des soucis de-
Non.
...maladie mentale.
Mais non ? Attends, on va revenir là-dessus dans un instant, si tu permets. Mais donc en tout cas, tu n'es pas d'accord avec l'idée que par défaut
toutes les personnes folles soient violentes, dangereuses quoi.
C'est même pas une question que je sois pas d'accord, c'est les chiffres qui le disent.
En fait, y a des statistiques qui existent et c'est pour ça que je t'ai dit non en répétition, c'est que les
études le montrent très clairement, les personnes folles sont bien plus sujettes de violence que leur cause.
Voilà, j'ai plus les chiffres en tête, mais c'est assez énorme. Et quand on-
Ouais, c'est vrai qu'on en parle peu, ouais.
Voilà. Et on passe notre temps à le répéter, ces chiffres, ils existent. Et ensuite quand on regarde, parce qu'on vient nous...
les médias aiment bien, dès qu'y a effectivement un schizophrène qui a tué quelqu'un, on en parle pendant X temps et on met bien l'accent sur ça.
Par rapport à tous les crimes commis, les meurtres, etc., même là, les schizophrènes sont une minorité. On est que dalle.
Les school shooting, les mass murder aux États-Unis, là encore, la plupart ne sont pas des malades mentaux. C'est des gens qui sont neurotypiques.
Voilà. Et ce qu'on oublie de dire, c'est que même quand tu es une personne folle qui commet une de ces atrocités-là, tu le fais pas parce que t'es folle.
Tu le fais parce que t'as des idées de merde, tout simplement. Quand une personne schizophrène passe à l'acte, elle le fait pas parce que juste elle est schizophrène en fait.
Elle le fait parce qu'elle a été socialisée de sorte à croire que bah oui, c'était une réponse. La violence, c'était une réponse.
Elle le fait parce qu'elle a une idéologie fasciste, accessoirement. Y a beaucoup ça dans les meurtres de masse.
Et ça, c'est pas la folie en fait. C'est différent. Tu peux avoir des idées de merde en étant schizophrène aussi hein.
C'est pas incompatible, ça, malheureusement. Mais c'est pas la folie qui fait que t'es un raciste ou qui fait que t'es fasciste et que tu te dis que ouvrir le feu dans un lieu public, c'est OK.
C'est pas ça le lien en fait.
OK. Donc tu dis, ces cas-là sont extrêmement minoritaires.
Mmh.
Donc on peut peut-être imaginer qu'il y a des situations où ça a été un facteur, mais c'est jamais l'essentiel de la réponse quoi.
C'est ça. On va pas nier que ça existe puisque bah c'est un fait hein, ça existe. Tout simplement parce que les criminels, t'as un peu toutes les populations qui sont représentées.
Donc il est logique que t'aies aussi des schizophrènes dans le lot, mais on est finalement pas plus nombreux que dans la société civile quoi.
Mmh, mmh. Alors, je...
y a un instant, tu évoquais l'idée qu'on ait envie de, bah quelque part diagnostiquer, pathologiser, les personnes qui ont des comportements problématiques, en l'occurrence, les gens qui font des mass murder.
Peut-être que je pars complètement à trois kilomètres du sujet hein, tu me dis : « Ça n'a rien à voir ». Mais un truc qui est assez récurrent, j'ai l'impression,
'fin, en tout cas, je pense en France et en Belgique, c'est... on va croiser une personne avec un comportement problématique.
Typiquement, ça va être son ex et on va dire que cette personne est, et alors on va sortir de pseudo diagnostics de pervers narcissique, des choses comme ça.
Est-ce que ça, là encore, c'est pas, et je veux surtout pas mettre une réponse dans ta bouche, mais est-ce que c'est pas
emblématique d'un système, d'une société où on diabolise les problèmes de santé mentale et où, dès qu'un comportement est jugé
désagréable, ou pas accepté dans notre société, on va le pathologiser.
Est-ce qu'on a tendance à surpathologiser les comportements-
Ouais.
...dans notre culture ?
Ah très clairement. On pathologise à l'extrême. Et alors y a plein de choses qui se croisent hein, dans les différents exemples que tu dis.
Le classique de l'ex folle, en général, ça marche bien dans un sens. C'est bien folle, F-O-L-L-E hein, généralement.
C'est des ex folles. Donc ça, c'est-
Ou pervers narcissique si c'est un homme aussi ouais.
Voilà, pervers narcissique va plutôt être un homme, et c'est un autre problème. L'ex folle, on a vraiment tout ce côté extrêmement sexiste qui se traduit là,
où on prend pas en compte que le comportement qu'on a considéré comme de la folie était causé par les comportements de, bah du mec en général.
Et mais si tu dis que c'est ton ex et qu'elle était folle, du coup toi t'as rien à te reprocher tu vois. C'est bon, l'ex elle était folle, moi j'suis clean.
Donc ça, c'est plutôt un produit du sexisme, effectivement, cette pathologisation là. Le pervers narcissique, ça a fait couler beaucoup d'encre, parce qu'effectivement, c'est pas un diagnostic qui existe.
Bon après ceux qui existent, c'est de la merde aussi, mais ça on y vient plus tard. On y vient doucement, mais...
Mais parce qu'en fait quand tu creuses, là c'est pareil en fait c'est beaucoup de comportements,
nerdiques, mais qui sont pathologisés plutôt que d'être reconnus comme un problème de socialisation et donc un problème de société finalement, de comment on demande aux gens d'agir, comment on les fait se comporter, etc.
Donc c'est un vaste problème. La pathologisation en général, c'est un vaste problème, d'autant que ça se fait aussi pour les idées politiques.
Tu vois, quand tu veux décrédibiliser ton adversaire, la première chose qui vient c'est de le traiter de schizo ou d'autiste quoi.
Le truc à la mode en ce moment—
C'est effectivement la première idée qui me vient en effet.
Voilà, tu vois, c'est un classique. Là le truc à la mode depuis quelques semaines sur le Twitter français, c'est de dire que Macron il a un TDI parce qu'il a changé d'avis sur j'sais pas quoi.
Oh là là !
Classique bullshit, tu sais.
Oh là là.
Voilà, ça, ça n'a—
Mais je comprendrai jamais comment les gens arrivent à employer des mots. Ils doivent être conscients du fait qu'ils ne savent pas ce que ça veut dire, qu'ils n'y connaissent rien.
Mais arriver à employer des mots alors qu'ils sont conscients du fait qu'ils savent pas ce que ça veut dire, c'est—
Mais ce qui— ils savent pas ce que— non. Oui, t'as raison, ils savent pas ce que ça veut dire au sens où ils savent pas ce que ça représente vraiment.
Par contre, ils savent que c'est quelque chose qui est mal vu dans notre société, qui est décrié et qui est considéré comme mauvais, qui est péjoratif.
Et que donc si tu accuses ton adversaire en premier— ça par contre, faut tirer la carte en premier hein, sinon ça marche pas.
On peut pas faire celui qui dit qui est, avec une insulte qui frappe,
ça ne marche pas. Voilà, si t'arrives à tirer cette carte-là en premier, t'as décrédibilisé ton adversaire justement parce que comme on le disait au début,
on est considérés comme des gens qui ne pouvons pas réfléchir, qui ne pouvons pas appartenir à la société, qui ne pouvons pas y apporter quoi que ce soit et qui du coup ne peuvent pas produire un avis,
mesuré, pertinent—
C'est ça.
...intéressant, etc. Donc et donc t'as ça pour les personnes publiques, mais faut savoir aussi que, du coup, la pathologisation des idées politiques, ça se fait aussi à notre niveau.
C'est-à-dire que justement, si une personne folle, une personne malade mentale commence à dire : « Peut-être que quand même, les institutions, ça craint, ça nous maltraite, etc. »
Les soignants vont dire : « Ah ouais, mais vous dites ça parce que vous êtes dans le déni ou parce que vous êtes paranoïaque, etc. »
Tu vois ? C'est pas des vraies idées, c'est nous qui délirons. Ça marche aussi dans ce sens-là.
Alors j'avais promis qu'on terminerait en parlant de psychiatrie, d'antipsychiatrie. Comment est-ce que tu as le sentiment d'être perçue par, par exemple, les personnes qui t'ont diagnostiquée ?
Alors ça date. Et puis surtout, j'ai fait en sorte de plus être confrontée à la psychiatrie depuis. Mais à l'époque, donc j'avais 20 ans tout juste, je me suis sentie extrêmement infantilisée.
Avec cette sensation que si je les laissais faire— parce que moi, à l'époque, pour remettre dans le contexte, donc j'étais suivie par un psychiatre
qui a décidé— donc c'était pendant une année où j'étais revenue chez mes parents parce que j'étais vraiment plus en état de faire des études ni de vivre tout seul, j'étais complètement pété.
Donc pendant un an, j'ai vécu chez mes parents comme ça. J'étais suivie par un psychiatre, psychiatre qui a décidé que je devrais aller passer une demi-journée par semaine en hôpital de jour.
Donc je sais pas si vous avez ce truc-là en Belgique. Comment décrire les hôpitaux de jour ? C'est un peu une garderie géante pour adultes.
Le but du jeu, officiellement, c'est de te socialiser, c'est-à-dire que tu gardes un lien, tu vois, que tu sois pas trop replié sur toi-même.
Et autant, tu vois, nous, dès qu'on fait un truc, c'est pathologique, autant dès que tu le fais avec un soignant, c'est thérapeutique.
Donc un après-midi par semaine, j'allais là-bas et pendant une moitié d'année, je faisais l'atelier promenade.
Donc voilà, on allait se promener pendant deux heures. Et l'autre partie de l'année, c'était l'atelier jeux de société où les soignants ont décrypté que puisque j'aimais bien les mots, j'aimais bien le Scrabble.
Spoiler alert, je détestais le Scrabble déjà avant. Aujourd'hui, si vous me faites jouer au Scrabble, je vous fais bouffer le plateau.
Je ressens une grande solidarité pour toi maintenant que t'as parlé de Scrabble.
Merci. Voilà. Et donc l'hôpital de jour, donc
j'y suis, je suis le plus jeune, parce que j'ai 20 ans, mais la plupart des gens qui y sont ont— y en a deux qui avaient la trentaine et après tous les autres avaient 40, 50 ans et plus.
Mh.
Donc voilà, c'est très étrange. Et tu—
Mais donc là, tu parles de ton expérience en hôpital de jour, comme quoi c'était pas super agréable parce que tu devais jouer au Scrabble.
Mais ce que je voudrais explorer avec toi, c'est surtout la façon dont le corps médical—
J'y viens ouais.
Oui, vas-y, je t'en prie.
Ce que je voulais parler, c'est— 'fin, en fait, j'en parle parce que justement, c'est le regard.
C'est justement cette sensation-là de : c'est comme ça que me voient les psys, en fait. On t'envoie là et en fait, tu fais rien.
Le temps, il passe et t'es juste là, tu joues au Scrabble, tu vas te promener dans la ville. Et on attend rien d'autre de toi, en fait.
Et on ne t'ouvre aucune autre porte et tu sens bien que les soignants ne voient pas d'autre avenir pour toi que : tu viens la semaine prochaine.
Mh.
Y a cette sensation d'impasse, et d'infantilisation, mais sur tout. Parce que du coup, je devais fêter mes 20 ans et ils se sont tous mis : « Ah ben on va faire le menu ensemble » et tout.
Bah non, je t'ai rien demandé, en fait. 'Fin, voilà. Pis pas d'alcool, etc. 'fin, t'as vraiment cette espèce de truc très, très collant.
Infantilisant, ouais.
Voilà, hyper infantilisant. Et c'est vraiment ça le regard qu'avaient les soignants sur moi à cette époque-là.
C'était cette sensation-là. T'es infantilisé et on ne voit pas d'avenir pour toi de toute façon. Et tu vas juste être coulé dans cette espèce de truc-là où t'es sage et où t'en passes.
Et, mais tu n'es pas tout seul renfermé, alors c'est mieux.
Maintenant, si on parle alors de l'autre aspect de la question qui est— on n'en a pas parlé depuis le début. Je suis certain que beaucoup de gens sont surpris et se demandent : mais
Mais est-ce que dans des lieux on prend des médicaments ?
Non.
Oui, implicitement, on avait compris que non. Mais est-ce que, voilà, est-ce que tu peux parler de ton rapport à la médication et pourquoi tu ne prends pas de médicaments du coup ?
Mon rapport à la médication est très mauvais puisqu'il relève du traumatisme chez moi. Donc j'ai été sous antipsychotiques pendant quatre ans.
Et ça m'a laissé quelques séquelles. Il est mauvais parce que c'est par là que je me suis rendu compte qu'on s'en fichait de ce que je disais, de ce que je ressentais.
C'est-à-dire qu'à la toute base, c'est ma médecin qui me les a prescrits en premier lieu. Elle était vraiment partie sur une idée que c'est ponctuel le temps que je reprenne pied, etc.
Et donc tant que ça a été elle qui gérait ça, ça a été effectivement ponctuel. Pendant un an et demi, j'étais sous traitement plusieurs mois, on arrêtait et je repartais après en crise, etc.
Et on a vraiment géré comme ça. Et quand je suis passée chez le psychiatre, déjà, on a augmenté les doses régulièrement.
Là où c'était drôle, c'est que plus je disais que ça me rendait malade, plus on augmentait les doses. Ironiquement, plus on augmentait les doses, plus je faisais de crises.
Mais du coup, leur réponse était de continuer à augmenter les doses. Je disais donc que ça me rendait malade et personne m'a crue, en fait.
Personne m'a écoutée.
Donc on est encore dans une situation d'infantilisation du coup.
Ouais, c'est de l'infantilisation et c'est vraiment ce côté : nous, on sait. Et si toi, tu oses critiquer le traitement, c'est que tu es en déni de ta maladie, en fait.
Oui. Alors, juste, est-ce que— bon alors, je crois comprendre en écoutant le témoignage que c'est loin d'être une situation isolée, ce que tu nous racontes.
Mh.
Inversement, est-ce qu'on pourrait imaginer y a des médecins compétents qui sont à l'écoute de leurs patients, leurs patientes
et qui, 'fin du coup, ne pas infantiliser leurs patients, être à leur écoute et alors atteindre un scénario où, ben on trouve,
voilà, une situation confortable pour le patient et où la médication sert à quelque chose ou bien est-ce que la médication, ça n'est jamais pour le confort de la personne concernée et toujours plutôt pour celui de,
de la société, des médecins, de l'entourage ? Qu'est-ce que...
Alors là encore, c'est une question complexe. Je vais essayer de répondre au mieux. La légende raconte que oui, ce type de soignant existe.
Mais alors j'en ai pas parlé quand je t'ai envoyé l'invitation, mais j'ai interviewé y a deux ans, je crois, un docteur, un psychiatre qui travaille justement principalement avec des personnes schizophrènes.
Et, bon évidemment, j'ai pas parlé avec ses patients, mais voilà, le discours qu'il tenait me semblait pas trop— oh, je retire ce « pas trop », me semblait pas du tout méprisant, réifiant, infantilisant.
Et voilà, il avait plutôt l'air de défendre des valeurs qui me semblaient assez humaines. Mais donc, mais je veux bien croire que ce soit rare.
Alors, je vais pas parler pour cette personne parce que j'ai pas pu écouter cette interview puisque je veux pas juger, puis je veux pas te mettre en porte-à-faux non plus.
Mais c'est compliqué. C'est-à-dire la particularité de la psychophobie, et notamment dans la psychiatrie, et ce qu'il faut bien comprendre, c'est que pour beaucoup,
nos soignants n'ont pas l'impression de nous infantiliser ou de décider pour nous.
Mon psychiatre, si tu veux, c'était quand même— j'étais pas non plus tombée sur quelqu'un de spécialement maltraitant ni rien, en fait.
Il essayait plutôt de m'écouter. Par contre, il avait cette certitude qu'il savait mieux et qu'effectivement, si je tenais ce discours-là, c'est parce que,
voilà, c'était propre à ma folie et que si on avait le bon traitement, ça allait passer.
Et y en a beaucoup qui sont dans cette optique-là, en fait, qui se disent pas consciemment :
« Cette personne-là, elle vit de la merde » ou elle peut pas le dire, mais qui partent du principe que puisqu'on est malades mentaux, on ne peut pas avoir suffisamment de recul sur ce que l'on vit pour pouvoir prendre une décision.
Typiquement, moi, le retour que j'ai souvent, que ce soit sur Twitter ou avec d'autres soignants, c'est que je suis trop lucide pour être fou, en fait.
Et c'est un truc que les gens ont beaucoup, au point que je connais des gens qui ont effectivement dû simuler des crises devant un psy pour avoir le droit d'être pris au sérieux et d'être suivis correctement.
Ouais. Quand tu dis ça, ça fait écho
aux personnes autistes qui sont pas prises comme telles et qui, du coup, au moment d'avoir une chance de peut-être, parce que pour certains, pour nombre d'entre nous, on cherche un diagnostic pour obtenir les aides.
Mh.
Et alors effectivement, y a ce truc où, ben on va se forcer à regarder par terre pour avoir l'air autiste ou je sais pas, donc.
Voilà.
C'est, ouais, y a ce truc effectivement où—
C'est là où tu accentues des côtés—
C'est ça.
...des traits caricaturaux que t'as pas—
...et qui sont assumés. Voilà, donc y a ça aussi de notre côté. Donc y a ce problème-là, déjà de base.
Autre problème qui vient se rajouter, c'est que même si on part du principe que les antipsychotiques peuvent être effectivement utiles à un moment donné pour une personne, le truc, c'est que c'est censé être ponctuel.
C'est des traitements qui sont censés être ponctuels. T'sais, les études menées sur ce traitement le disent clairement, c'est : les antipsychotiques, c'est six mois maximum.
Après, au mieux ça sert plus à rien—
Donc quand tu disais ponctuel, j'imaginais genre pendant un épisode psychotique, pendant une crise ou quoi, mais toi, tu dis jusqu'à six mois, c'est plus que ponctuel ça.
Oui, c'est plus que ponctuel là aussi, mais c'est-à-dire qu'entre six mois et toute ta vie, tu vois que six mois—
Tout est relatif.
Tout est relatif. Après, effectivement, oui, y a des personnes, ça peut être encore sur du plus court terme, tu vois. Mais en tout cas, ce que les études disent, c'est six mois maximum.
Après, au mieux, ça ne fait plus rien, au pire, ça empire la situation. Moi, c'est ce qui s'est passé. D'ailleurs, c'est pour ça qu'à chaque fois qu'on augmentait les doses, ben en fait, je faisais des crises encore plus violentes, etc.
C'est des trucs qui sont documentés, tu vois, par la science psychiatrique elle-même. C'est assez fameux, c'est assez formidable.
Et le truc, c'est qu'on n'a pas cette utilisation-là ou très très peu, chez très peu de soignants, on a cette utilisation-là, puisque l'idée que, voilà,
c'est pour ça que tu m'as posé la question d'ailleurs, l'idée, c'est un schizophrène, pour qu'il soit stable, il peut pas vivre sans médicament.
Et ça, c'est une idée qui existe même chez les soignants en psychiatrie. Elle est inscrite.
Et c'est moi qui suis délirant après, alors que c'est littéralement des gens qui vont au contraire, à l'opposé de ce que leur propre science a prouvé, tu vois.
Parce que cette idée-là, elle l'emporte.
Donc c'est extrêmement compliqué puisque nous-mêmes, quand on vient chercher ces soins, tu vois, si t'as besoin à un moment d'antipsychotique pour toute ta vie, on te met dans la tête que ben ça sera toute ta vie.
Et c'est compliqué d'aller à l'encontre de ça si t'as pas les ressources. Parce que voilà, tu te dis : « Le soignant, il sait, c'est mieux, c'est son travail normalement de savoir. »
C'est pour ça que tu vas le voir. Tu peux pas avoir ce recul-là. Y a le fait que, quand tu— ce sont des traitements extrêmement addictifs.
Ça, c'est pareil, on le dit assez peu. Et du coup, quand tu arrêtes un traitement addictif, y a ce qu'on appelle les effets de sevrage.
Et si tu le sais pas, en fait, ça ressemble énormément à ta pathologie de base. Effectivement, quand t'arrêtes tes antipsychotiques, si t'as pas fait un sevrage correct, tu vas te retrouver à refaire des crises, etc.
Ou reavoir des pulsions suicidaires. Et du coup, c'est souvent interprété comme : « Ben tu vois bien que t'en as besoin, en fait », alors que c'est un effet de sevrage.
Donc t'as ça qui joue, et qui fausse un peu la donne parce qu'on n'est pas correctement accompagné là-dedans. Et le dernier point, tu disais : « Est-ce que du coup c'est bénéfique pour la personne ou est-ce que c'est que pour l'entourage ? »
Effectivement, tu vois, quand t'as des jeunes, tout ça, c'est compliqué. D'autant qu'il faut ajouter que,
ben on vit dans une société qui est quand même très utilitariste, quand même très basée sur ta capacité à produire, et à faire des choses
et que du coup, ben, ouais, si t'es dans une situation où t'as besoin d'aller travailler, ben on va rien te proposer d'autre, en fait.
Donc le traitement, tu vas le prendre parce que t'as besoin d'aller travailler et que t'as pas d'autres options. Donc c'est extrêmement compliqué.
Moi, je connais beaucoup de gens qui sont dans des situations compliquées où ils voudraient pouvoir arrêter les traitements,
mais ne peuvent pas parce que c'est trop compliqué de mettre en place, 'fin, de supporter les effets de sevrage ou parce que de toute façon, il faut aller au travail dans deux jours, en fait.
Et du coup, tu peux pas cumuler un sevrage et aller au travail. Et apprendre à vivre avec tes délires, avec tes hallucinations, ça prend du temps aussi.
Et ce temps-là, la société, elle te le donne pas ou très très peu.
Mh.
Donc c'est compliqué. Donc voilà, donc au final, oui, tu te retrouves à prendre des traitements parce que toi, t'en as besoin.
Et en plus de ça, y a une pression énorme, une pression sociale qui est donnée. Moi, effectivement, quand j'ai dit à mes proches que j'arrêtais les médicaments, ça a été compliqué parce que
pour eux aussi, même en étant bienveillants, ils pensaient que j'en avais vraiment besoin.
Et t'as souvent aussi des discours où ouais, tes proches te préfèrent sous médicament. 'Fin t'as vraiment des gens qui se sont entendus dire ça,
où la gestion de ta maladie mentale passe par les médicaments, quoi.
Passe, passe, passe—
Est-ce que toi, t'as dé— oui, non. Toi, tu n'as pas eu l'occasion personnellement d'entendre la phrase : « Je te préfère sous médicament. »
Mais est-ce que tu as le sentiment de, quand tu as été sous médicament, d'être une personne, d'exister de manière foncièrement différente ?
Est-ce que tu te reconnais, quand tu te vois sous médicament ?
Ma mémoire de l'époque, elle est explosée, à la fois à cause de la folie, parce que du coup, c'est vraiment l'époque où j'étais le plus délirant, et à cause des médicaments.
Parce que ce qu'on dit pas, c'est que les médicaments ont un impact cognitif assez lourd, en fait. Donc moi, ils ont niqué ma mémoire sur cette période-là, et d'autres trucs au passage.
Et surtout, 'fin, j'avais encore moins d'émotions et j'étais coupée d'une partie de moi.
Donc non, je me reconnais pas parce que tout ce qui restait, c'était ce qui me faisait suffisamment souffrir pour réussir à dépasser la barrière chimique.
Et j'ai vraiment des souvenirs comme ça où je me retrouvais à pleurer devant une amie en me disant : « Mais j'ai plus d'émotions, je ressentirai plus jamais rien », 'fin.
Et en fait, c'était extrêmement dû aux médicaments qui ont complètement anesthésié tout ça. Donc non, je me reconnais pas.
Quand j'y repense, je me reconnais pas de l'époque où j'étais sous médicament. Et en plus, moi, ça me rendait extrêmement délirant.
J'étais convaincue d'avoir une espèce de bouillie noire, de pourri sur moi, et je suis allée très très loin pour réussir à la virer, en fait, de mon sang quoi.
Donc paradoxalement, moi, ça m'a fait énormément de mal et j'ai failli en mourir quoi.
Mmh. Et donc on parlait du fait que pour l'instant — 'fin d'ailleurs je sais plus si on l'a dit, mais en tout cas on en a parlé en off.
Pour l'instant donc tu ne travailles pas, tu as mis en pause la rédaction de ta thèse d'université.
Si, je suis sur la rédaction de ma thèse.
OK pardon.
Je n'ai plus de travail salarié, on va le dire comme ça.
OK. Donc si on imagine ta vie, c'est toujours difficile hein, mais dans quelques années, quand il sera sans doute
mieux de percevoir un salaire, est-ce que ça va être un challenge pour toi ou est-ce que tu sens que tu vas pouvoir y arriver, de le faire donc sans médicament ?
Alors, sans médicament, oui, c'est pas la difficulté parce que ça fait plus de 10 ans maintenant moi que j'ai arrêté et j'ai toujours réussi jusque-là à éviter, même si j'ai régulièrement, régulièrement
recroisé des médecins qui avaient décrété que ça résoudrait tous mes problèmes depuis.
Mais donc ça, c'est pas le sans médicament qui sera une difficulté. La question que je me pose moi pour l'après-thèse, c'est effectivement dans quelles conditions je peux aller travailler pour que ça se passe bien.
En fait, la réponse, elle est pas évidente puisque les domaines dans lesquels je peux travailler sont des domaines qui sont en train de se faire détruire et surprécariser.
Du coup, c'est pas évident de se projeter. La différence par rapport à y a quelques années, c'est que je sais maintenant que je suis handicapée et qu'il faut que je le prenne en compte.
C'est une réalisation qui est relativement récente dans mon parcours, et que je peux pas travailler plus d'un mi-temps par semaine, par exemple.
Donc c'est comment je fais pour orchestrer tout ça. Ça, j'ai pas encore la réponse, mais c'est un problème pour le moi du futur après la soutenance.
Ouais, un problème pour le toi du futur.
C'est ça.
Mais donc voilà, on sent que ça va être une question importante et ouais, à laquelle tu n'as pas encore la réponse.
Donc on a largement dépassé les 70 minutes comme tu le vois. Est-ce qu'il reste un sujet que tu voudrais aborder ?
Oui, au final, on n'a pas eu le temps de parler d'antipsychiatrie à proprement parler.
Ah ben oui. Je me disais bien qu'il manquait quelque chose. Oui, bah vas-y, explique-nous.
Voilà, en quelques mots, puisque comme tu l'as dit, on a déjà très largement dépassé le temps. L'idée de l'antipsychiatrie, c'est finalement de se débarrasser de l'institution psychiatrique comme elle
est, puisque finalement, c'est de se rendre compte que le système psychiatrique est un système de contrôle plus qu'un système de soins.
C'est un système qui vise la normalisation de l'individu et non pas son bien-être. Ce sont deux choses qui sont souvent très très différentes.
Et du coup, ce que les militants antipsychiatrie visent, c'est plutôt d'avoir des systèmes de pair-aidance, mais alors pas encore comme ce qui existe aujourd'hui hein, c'est encore très insuffisant,
mais où on aurait des,
des vrais lieux de repos, des vrais groupes communautaires qui puissent permettre de prendre en compte les difficultés des individus et de leur donner bah un peu tout ce qu'on a pu évoquer, à savoir le temps,
pour comprendre comment ça fonctionne hein, quand tu es autiste, quand tu es schizophrène, comment tu fonctionnes, te donner ce temps-là, te donner les ressources de fonctionner en tant que toi,
et non pas en tant que toi qui serais suffisamment normalisé pour pouvoir rentrer dans les rouages de la société capitaliste et collectiviste.
Voilà, et d'avoir des vraies solidarités comme ça, mais ça demande aussi un changement de société assez profond, on va dire.
Et donc l'antipsychiatrie n'est pas refuser de soigner et d'aider les gens, contrairement à ce qu'on me dit régulièrement.
C'est une autre façon de le faire et c'est de le faire réellement en prenant la personne en compte et non pas en cherchant à la casser pour qu'elle rentre dans un moule.
Et est-ce que tu dirais que dans les personnes qui t'accompagnent, parce que j'imagine que tu as une psy ou un psy, est-ce que dans les personnes qui t'accompagnent, tu retrouves un système qui te plaît ?
Est-ce que tu es satisfaite à ce niveau-là ou est-ce que tu cherches encore ?
Moi, j'ai une psychologue, mais ce que j'aimerais vraiment, c'est de pouvoir vraiment avoir des, ouais ce que je disais, des lieux de repos, puisqu'il y a des fois où je vais vraiment très très mal, tu vois.
Ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure, le début de la pandémie, le premier confinement, j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir rentrer chez mes parents, mais j'ai frôlé l'internement sous contrainte.
Et donc ce dont moi j'aurais besoin, c'est effectivement d'avoir des lieux où tu vas un jour, deux jours, tu pètes ton câble dans un endroit qui soit un minimum — non, mais c'est vraiment ça.
C'est-à-dire que y a un moment, tu peux pas éviter de faire ta crise en fait, tu peux pas éviter la décompensation. Et du coup, l'idée, ce serait de pouvoir mettre en place des stratégies de damage control
et de pouvoir faire cette crise-là, cette décompensation-là dans un lieu où tu serais vraiment à l'abri et où si tu, voilà, tu pètes ta pile, eh ben après, tu vas pas être attachée dans une chambre d'isolement, sur,
sur-médicamentée et tout, en fait.
Des fois, y a besoin en fait que le système explose pour pouvoir repartir. Donc on a besoin de lieux où on pourrait,
où ça pourrait se faire et où du coup, après, éventuellement, bah voilà, si tu t'es mutilé, ben on t'aide à te soigner, on vérifie que y a pas trop de dégâts,
on voit avec toi quoi faire pour que tu repartes à peu près sainement, etc.
Enfin voilà, juste ça. Et pas d'être dans un truc hyper de contrôle plus plus plus, enfin voilà, c'est pas idéal quoi.
Très bien. Bah merci beaucoup Dandelion. On espère que le message est passé, que les autorités seront très inspirées en t'écoutant.
On y croit. Est-ce qu'il y a un endroit où les auditeurs, les auditrices peuvent te retrouver et te lire ?
Bah sur mon Twitter, ça semble le plus efficace.
Ouais, je vais mettre le lien alors en description.
Voilà, sur mon Twitter et puis sur mon Medium, c'est là que j'écris régulièrement.
Super. Et donc tu écris principalement au sujet de la folie, la psychophobie et les sujets qu'on a abordés aujourd'hui.
Voilà.
Très bien. Bah merci beaucoup et on se retrouve alors dans deux semaines pour un prochain épisode. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Voilà, j'espère que ça vous a plu. J'espère que ça vous aura permis d'élargir vos horizons. Donner la parole aux personnes dont on parle, mais qu'on n'entend jamais, ça fait très clairement partie de la mission que je me suis donnée.
Et qui sait, peut-être qu'il y en a parmi vous qui vont arrêter d'employer le mot schizophrène de manière péjorative et sans en connaître la définition.
Qui sait ? J'ai aussi trouvé très intéressante la discussion qu'on a eue sur la tendance qu'on a à pathologiser les comportements toxiques.
C'est quelque chose que je vois assez fréquemment autour de moi, mais non, désolé. Je sais que c'est dur, mais voilà, les connards toxiques sont avant tout des connards toxiques et pas des malades mentaux.
Je le rappelle, dans un mois, je donnerai une formation sur la discipline de l'interview. Ça aura lieu à Saint-Gilles, mais grande nouvelle, on a fait en sorte que la formation soit joignable en distanciel.
Donc si vous êtes loin de Bruxelles et que vous n'avez pas la possibilité de venir en personne, foncez, le lien est en description.
Dans deux semaines, je recevrai un invité politique de premier plan.
Ensuite, comme promis, j'essaierai d'explorer au plus vite les sujets comme les troubles du comportement alimentaire, l'antisémitisme et aussi faire un édito supplémentaire. À très vite. Bye !